with each passing day the popularity of
blockchain technology grows as to the
reason to learn blockchain
however understanding of blockchain
technology has remained limited to the
realm of cryptocurrency
blockchain technology on the other hand
has been revolutionizing different
industries throughout the world
blockchain technology which was
introduced in the aftermath of the
global financial crisis of 2008 has
challenged many traditional beliefs
about computing
there are a variety of reasons to learn
about blockchain technology and its
applications in many industries
and that is what we are here for
hey everyone welcome to this new video
of simply learn on the top 10 reasons to
learn blockchain in 2022
in this video we will be discussing some
of the major factors that ensure why
learning blockchain is going to be an
essential part of 2022
but before proceeding let's have a quick
glimpse over what is
blockchain
blockchain is a distributed digitalized
ledger technology that uses a
point-to-point network to allow for
valid and exceptionally secure
transactions every block in the ledger
has a cryptographic link to the block in
the chain preceding it as well as a
timestamp
it was first introduced in 2008 and put
into practice in 2009 it is a technology
that allows anyone to utilize bitcoin
since then blockchain has grown in
popularity and has become more
beneficial in a variety of fields
following bitcoin a blockchain network
has been used to run a variety of
cryptocurrencies
blockchain is proving to be a valuable
in sectors such as governance cyber
security
industrial process
the financial sector entertainment and
more in addition to cryptocurrency
so now let's get into the most exciting
part of the video
that is the reason to learn blockchain
so at the 10th position we have
entertainment for all
blockchain is the ideal technology for
eliminating middleman from the content
distribution process
for example
an artist may use blockchain to upload
their song to the cloud as an encrypted
file
the song can then be requested directly
by an interested listener for a fee
the creator can just directly distribute
a copy of their content to the consumer
thanks to the peer-to-peer networking
infrastructure
for example
we now utilize spotify and sovereign to
stream and listen to music these apps
too serve as intermediaries
now every time you listen to when
taylor's fifth song money goes to
spotify leaving the singer with a very
small royalty
to avoid this the artist can submit
their music to the cloud as an encrypted
file using blockchain
the song can then be requested directly
by an interested listener for a little
fee
then at the ninth position comes
transparency and improved governance
a transparent and responsible government
is the most critical aspect of any
country's ability to function almost the
majority of the country's governance is
open
meaning citizens are not involved in the
procedures or decision making
so transparency and legitimacy can be
achieved by incorporating blockchain
into governance
systems such as taxes elections welfare
healthcare and so on
countries such as germany the united
kingdom and australia are already
developing plans to include blockchain
into their governing operations in order
to verify tax compliance keep digital
documents and make welfare payments
among other things
dubai on the other hand has already
successfully integrated blockchain into
its official activities making it the
first government to do so
after that at the eighth position we
have cryptocurrencies and
icos if you have a genuine interest in
investing in cryptocurrency you must
have a solid understanding of the
blockchain and distributed ledger
technology systems
this is due to the fact that blockchain
is the underlying mechanism for such
currencies hence dealing with them
necessities and the use of blockchain if
you understand how blockchain works
you can make wise investments learning
blockchain will also help you better
understand and shortlist icos
then at the seventh position comes
career in cyber security
an individual can also claim greater
ownership and control over their digital
identity using the digitally encrypted
key
because
cyber security is one of the most
important needs in the tech industry
learning blockchain help you understand
your cybersecurity profession
and one of the most compelling reason to
understand blockchain is its role in
cyber security blockchain technology's
decentralized structure make it
impervious to hacker attempts aimed at
compromising sensitive data
blockchain delivers superior security
then traditional storage options
which rely on centralized and highly
secure storage
then comes at the sixth position we have
high demand for blockchain technology
since its inception blockchain has
continued to attract attention
credibility
and appeal
the market need for blockchain has
increased every year according to
statistics
this indicates that blockchain will
continue to be a domain with career
possibilities and business application
in the coming years
now at the fifth position comes digital
identity
now except for our grandparents and
great grandparents there must be very
few among us who do not utilize digital
banking or transaction services
this digital revolution has also
provided infamous hackers with millions
of opportunities to commit cyber crime
as a result our digital identities were
put into jeopardy
now blockchain will establish a strict
cryptographic system that will make
hacking and assessing information
difficult
additionally a person's digital identity
is preserved i.e there will be just one
online identity that may be used
wherever identity will be validated and
documented in a blockchain
and no one can commit digital fraud by
generating bogus identities
after that at the fourth position comes
new age technology information
blockchain provides a universal
architecture that can be easily
integrated with both old and new
technologies it can be used for voting
banking commodity trading and supply
chain management among other things
furthermore the blockchain smart
contracts and distributed ledger system
concepts are idle for the internet of
things
now we have reached the top three
reasons in which at the third position
we have the inflection point of an error
blockchain is said to create an
invention point of an error where many
significant players such as citibank
mastercard cibc visa sbi standard
chartered western union
censure jpmorgan and others are believed
to have integrated blockchain technology
this signifies that blockchain will
become a widely acknowledged technology
in no time
it will also open the floodgates to a
slew of new job openings as a result it
is preferable to ride the trending wave
and enjoy it while it
lasts now the second position we have
diversity of job roles
the second key point to consider when
learning blockchain is the wide range of
blockchain based employment
blockchain encompasses a wide range of
sector as well as technical skills
as a result blockchain talents not only
boost an individual's proficiency in a
certain technical function but also the
ability to produce business value
a closer look at the several major
employment titles in the blockchain
landscape might help to clear up any
misconceptions about whether or not
blockchain is worth learning
now comes the first and foremost reason
to learn blockchain
and that is promising career
since its introduction as a new concept
of running a cryptocurrency network
blockchain has grown in popularity as a
result there are an increasing number of
employment openings for blockchain
experts
blockchain professionals have titles
such as blockchain developer
cryptocurrency analyst blockchain
consultant blockchain solution architect
senior software engineer research
analyst and so on
as of 2021 a blockchain professional's
average compensation ranges from 1 lakh
twenty one thousand eight hundred
seventy five usd to one lakh eighty five
thousand two fifty usd
now blockchain will become more
mainstream in the future years offering
even
more work prospects for people
to sum up blockchain has a massive
global impact the benefits of learning
blockchain go beyond professional
potential and include opportunities to
gain new skills
so by understanding blockchain you can
get a job in a variety of professions
and build a reputation as a blockchain
cybersecurity expert
i hope you liked this video and learned
something new from it if you like this
video then please do hit the like button
thanks for watching this video and stay
tuned for more updates and videos from
simpler
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here